jetzt kommt wo
ich bin heute an für mario stars
challenge level 1 adr rock is to move
around
[Musik]
denn das kann doch nicht sagen was ihm
was falsch news.de rockies to move me
oder und kann ich dann hey komm mit
anlaufen
[Musik]
was mache ich denn falsch
das kann nicht sein ich musste doch
einfach nur plump die tri so ich muss
hier das rüber spiel nachdenken und
jetzt hier
[Musik]
ok hierüber hier auf
so und jetzt wohin denn sonst da sind
doch auch diese blöden hier und jetzt
[Musik]
hierüber hat wieso als dj louis baer
durch einen kurier war ingo holland
[Musik]
manchen moment in meinem leben wünschte
ich mir echt zum bock sagte man wisse
man dass es beispielsweise bei solchen
spielen der fall bei eventuell wenn ich
ein ganz klein wenig dass dann auch das
ist doch jetzt nicht wie weit kann ich
denn da an schwung nehmen
[Musik]
doch so ist dies blogs an denise niemals
so was jetzt
alles was ich jetzt machen wäre das
falsche freunde kann es denn wahr sein
[Musik]
es ist nicht wahr
ich glaube ich könnte noch ein
theoretisch hier entspringen erstmal ja
okay jetzt hier hin
hier oben draußen hier drunter ein
problem von king hier hin
[Musik]
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein
es ist nicht wahr ich habe plan
ok einfach gelaufen checkpoint ich freu
mich auf den checkpoint ganz ruhig luca
ich habe mich ja freuen
[Musik]
wieso mir das klar okay das ist so da
kann doch nicht das ist auch jetzt nicht
das ist doch so freunde
[Musik]
kann das nicht sein dass je näher ich
lasse mir als vieles gefallen
bruder mario wie soll man das denn
schaffen
ich bin hier über jetzt kommt wo freunde
jetzt gehen wir mal ganz viel
konzentration heran sorgen und jetzt
laufen hier überspringt
level es gibt noch ein level nicht mit
mir freunde ich bin raus die artkom ein
lang geht das ist so
ich sehe schon kommen wir sind wieder
irgendwelche falltüren die letzteren
letzte allerletzter ron das ist nicht
[Musik]